hello good morning thank you for coming
this morning and spending the day with
us my name is Monica burn jimenez I'm
from the komi college class of 88 and
teachers college class of two thousand
three I am on the Columbia lumini board
of directors and the president of Aquino
Alumni Association and actually it's
been a real honor for me to be chairing
the CAA alumni assembly committee so on
behalf of all of us we thank you for
coming and we welcome you today before
we get our program started I have
something interesting here ticket to the
Harvard game which apparently was found
downstairs so those of you who are
planning on going to the game check your
pockets if you don't hear from anybody
by lunch time we're going to raffle it
off that's my plan but I've got it if
it's yours please just come in and I
will be happy to give it to you and he
root for the Lions and all those really
good-looking young men that you saw
earlier with their ties that I'll look
and dress up that was our football team
they had breakfast this morning and they
are raring to go go lions beat crimson
that was like a cub actually i also want
to just point out and thank very quickly
of the members of the committee that
made my job super super easy apostolis
apostolic asst Joe Ehrlich and roof
Ellingham fry okarche Donna Rosenthal
and Brian Swain they will be out and
about today um and so please you know if
you have any questions about our
thinking about today or if anything you
want to be more involved please feel
free to talk to any of us I also want to
give a special thank you to the members
of the CAA staff again they make our job
super easy and make us look really good
but they're the ones that do all the
work and of course we couldn't do any of
this without them so special thank you
um many of you joined us last night at
the club for this amazing panel that was
moderated by president Bollinger last
night and it was really inspiring to
hear
hear about different perspectives on
alumni service and to sort of get a
sense of what drives them and what makes
them passionate about their belief in
changing the world I think Dale had said
at one point there was a question about
the issue of the recession and at one
point he said recession creates hardship
but does it destroy compassion he says I
don't think so and there was other
conversation about how well the needs
may also be going up the level of
volunteerism and service is also going
up and so there seems to be this real
sort of empathy and understanding about
helping each other through some
difficult times that many people are
feeling so it was really inspiring you
know I left and went home and I was
ready to like go back today and just
have a wonderful day and continue this
conversation about leadership and
service personal challenges geographic
structural challenges and how we
overcome them to really make an impact
not just on our communities but on
columbia and the work of the alumni
around the world so as we were getting
together as a committee to plan for this
we really listened to some of the
feedback we got last year and tried to
respond to making this day more
interactive and in a way more personal
and and helping people connect
personally around issues that were
important to them so we hope that you
find the opportunities are available to
you today engaging and provocative
informative we hope you'll bring your
critical mind to some of the issues and
raise those questions just as Colombia
taught us or trained us and and and we
hope that you'll continue you leave here
inspired to continue to do your service
to continue to build a leadership of
others in your community and continue to
contribute to Colombia it's my distinct
pleasure to introduce someone who has
been a an amazing guy a real role model
for those of us who are sort of you know
coming up in the ranks of alumni
leadership and and he's someone who
personally has been really important to
me and the way that I want to be when I
grow up he was just been oh he's too
of the columbia alumni association he's
newly appointed trustee of Columbia
University yay so Jim Hardin please
welcome Jim Martin